sinon ce candidat au permis va devoir
encore patienter avant de pouvoir
obtenir le précieux sésame après deux
mois sans conduire il faut bien souvent
se remettre à niveau
c'est problématique parce que les ailes
d'apprendre plusieurs vieux qu'ils ont
été coupés pendant des mois beaucoup
plus d'heures déjà par là qu'à la
normale plus le fait d'attendre
donc ils doivent encore prendre des
heures donc forcément ça fera des
frontistes et avec des demandes de cours
en hausse et des passages d'examens en
baisse restrictions sanitaire oblige
c'est l'embouteillage assuré on a
beaucoup de demandes de commandeur de
conduite mais pas de place de permis
donc deux mois de retard à rattraper de
nouvelles consignes à appliquer ici pas
de housse en plastique sur les sièges
chaque moniteur nettoie méthodiquement
son véhicule entre chaque cours
on a préféré la désinfection tout
simplement parce que comme on n'a pas
besoin on n'a pas droit la climatisation
les fenêtres sont ouvertes et le vent
avec les housses en plastique
c'est très désagréable masque
obligatoire durant chaque leçon et vizir
de rigueur pour les inspecteurs et les
moniteurs durant l'examen ce jeune
conducteur vient d'obtenir son permis il
se réjouit de ne pas avoir été obligé de
porter la visière la visière faut quand
même maîtrisé et conduit c'est par
exemple pour faire tous les angles morts
contrôle peut quelquefois que des soucis
de la vue aussi donc c'est vrai que
c'est tout un tas de conditions
auxquelles il faut s'adapter
avant de fêter l'obtention de leur
permis beaucoup de candidats devront
prendre leur mal en patience pour ce
mois de juin cette auto-école a perdu un
tiers de ses places à l'examen